hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the world fish random championship
Magnus Carlsen versus Wesley so Magnus
defeated
Fabiana Caruana in the semi-finals
whereas Wesley so defeated yummy pony
she and now the two of them are gonna
brawl it out this is the same as in the
semifinals of for Class 4 games followed
by for rapid games and then if the match
is still not decided they go into the
for blitz games classical games raked
the most points so you get three points
for a win so without further ado let's
check it out cross and in the first game
has the white pieces and as you can see
the setup of the pieces is almost
similar to actual chess and the rook and
Queen having their places switched so
some of the ideas that work in you know
just a regular chest might work here so
Carlsen opens with c4
almost as if he's going for the English
with East six nights to see three d5 by
black and now d4 so similar setup to the
to the may be some sort of a Queen's
Gambit we have D captures on c4 sort of
accepting the gambit III preparing to
recapture with the bishop so a lot of
ideas similar this is not all that
different we have a six preparing b5
soul magnets prevents it with a four and
now b6 preparing to fianchetto the light
square Bishop Bishop captures on c4 and
now Bishop to b7 and now Queen to be one
you might think but why not defend here
as the g2 point is under attack well
Queen B 1 and if you do something like
this then you get Queen captures on h7
you have to be careful the rook is not
on a trait so you might you know forget
this as it is Fischer random and now
you're just lost here so of course
Wesley defends with Knight to g6 and now
II for not allowing a bunch of
characters and g2
we have Bishop to b4 now attacking the
defender of d4 pawn so if you capture
and c3 then you can capture it on e4
we have Knights the g3 developing well
defending and c5 now so everything very
very principle that we have d5 by Magnus
he captures
he captures and now as the e-file is
opened both players decide that it's
safest the castle we have castles King
side castles King side and Knight to e5
now by Wesley we have diversified c4 is
under attack
back to a2 and now C for Wesley closes
off the light square bishop and for the
moment it's the the most useless piece
on the board we have Queen to e4
centralizing the Queen also may be
preparing radius like a bishop to be one
getting that Bishop to to a nicer
diagonal as soon as possible
and now Bishop captures and c3b captures
in the rook to e8 so nicely developing
here not worrying about Bishop to be one
threatening on h7 because Knight to g6
just prevents all of that and also open
up city attack from the roof to the
Queen
so Bishop captures on c4 by Magnus and
now Knight B to d7 continuing
development you could grab a light
square Bishop here but you don't really
gain anything by it you could do it but
Wesley prefers to get his pieces into
the interplay with Knight bd7 and now
Knight to f5 by Magnus just putting a
piece in front of the black King it
might come in useful with Knight to f6
attacking the Queen also adding another
attacker to the d5 pawn and Queen to h4
now and here Wesley is now ready to pick
off the d5 pawn we have special
characters on d5 Bishop characters with
rook after sandy five blue characters
and now Knight characters on d5 grabbing
it grabbing with the Queen would be too
dangerous if Queen captures then you get
Knight captures in g7 and black is in a
whole lot of trouble so here Wesley
plays Knight captures on d5 but Magnus
still goes for Knight captures on g7 and
what's the idea behind that chapters in
g7 well the Wesley says King captures on
g7 and he asks the same what's what's
the idea here so the point is you want
to get Bishop to h6 in but the problem
is if you do it right away but for page
six King h8 you don't have Queen to f6
I followed by Queen g7 mate because the
night from d5 is well the knife from d5
is guarding f6 so first before Bishop to
h6 Magnus prepares it with c4 now if
Wesley moves the knight then Bishop h6
will be winning so Wesley of course
doesn't do that he plays rook the e6 he
has to get another defender there to the
sixth rank and now Queens the g3 check
now the rook cannot block Wesley would
very much like play to play
to Jesus but then you get Queen captures
here with check so we have night back to
g6 and only now seek actress on d5 with
Queen captures on d5 by Wesley and now
h3 so 4 points each it's Bishop against
the night with a wasted skiing a bit a
bit loose
we have looked ito getting the rook to
to a very active second ring but now
Bishop to e3
Magnus closes it and now b5 Wesley now
once they create a passport on the Queen
side we have looked the c1 Magnus trying
to trick Wesley here into pushing b4
sort of creating a passport right away
but this would be losing it would be
losing due to queen g4 twin g4 is such a
nice move that wins the game black
doesn't really have a good square for
the rook so here you would either have
to give up the exchange and you wouldn't
have very good compensation for that
because if for example Ruby - Bishop d4
check just picks up the rook and if you
go look to a - it's not much better
still brush up the d4 check and now if
the King goes anywhere along the back
rank you're just gonna go look the c8
that's game over and if you go to h6
then looked c5 and now it's again game
over if the Queen moves the rook to h5
will be made if you don't move the Queen
you pretty much have to go for rook e1
check King h2 Queen d6 check g3 and
again you don't really have a good
defense against this you haven't changed
anything if f6 making a square for your
King just look at five you're gonna
you're gonna pick off this pawn next
still the look is still under attack
rook rook h5 store threat so white would
be completely winning here so after Luke
to see one Wesley doesn't fall for it
he notices that he needs some additional
as worse for the King and he also sets a
well tries to trick Magnus he plays the
h5 he tries to get Magnus into going
Luke the c5 so he would get sort of a if
the Queen moves you could pick up the h5
pawn but then Wesley has rook e1 check
King to h2 and now Queen the d1 check
and you don't have sufficient defense
against the rock h1 you have to clear
some space for a king for example Queen
g5 but now just Rock h1 King g3 and h4
wins the Queen as the black
Queen covers all of the light squares
here the knife covers a four so here you
would have to capture and give up the
Queen so everyone trying to trick
everyone a capture some b5 by Magnus not
interested in Roxy five for the moment a
captures and now kink to h2 now there
will be no rook e1 or queen to be one of
that will come with check and here there
are about nine minutes both of them and
it's only move twenty-nine they still
have to reach time control and there is
no increment here you should remember so
if things get out of control it's gonna
be you know who flex who first so here
as Wesley's King is a a bit more loose
than the Carlson's Wesley decided that
it's best here just the trade Queen so
Queen e5 we have Queen captures on e5
with Czech Knight captures and now rook
the c5 check west they had to calculate
precisely will he be able to to defend
here as Magnus is winning at least one
pawn so Wesley found night to d3 attacks
the rook and also the F to pawn which is
now attacked twice
we have rook captures on h5 and now
Wesley had to decide whether he wants to
go for b4 but once you put the room
behind the past point it's not a really
dangerous pond so Wesley decides to grab
a pond instead Knight captures an f2 now
making bishop on e3 a target so Carlson
first half has the play Bishop b4 check
we have King to g6 and only now rook
captures on b5 we have Knight to e4 and
now h4 by Magnus with f5 by Wesley and
now King to h3 we have rook to d2
attacking the bishop and now Ruby 6
check and here Wesley plays King to h5
everyone was very surprised here because
they allowed Bishop to e3
sort of an attack on the rook and also
threatening rook to h6 mate as the
bishop also covers the h6 square but
Wesley has a rook to d6 so that this
gets rid of both threats
rook the b5 attacking the f5 point and
now King to g6 and here Magnus played
rook the b3 so this is move 40 Wesley
needs to make one more move to reach
time control and he has four minutes to
do so so Wesley was rook to d1 preparing
rook to h1 check he's not a pawn but he
very confident that he will be able to
hold this we have g3 now rook to h1 with
check King to g2 and now look back the
e1 attacking the bishop looked the b6
with check and now King to f7 and by
Wesley I with Bishop to f4 and now rook
to itto again with check King to f3 look
to f2 with check King III and now rook
back to a2 we have kinked a sorry rook
to b3 now not allowing any more checks
and now Knight to f6 preparing to create
a blockade with Knight to h5 we have
Bishop back to be eight by Magnus just
you know feeling out the position
attesting out if Wesley will maybe make
a weird move or something we have worked
to a6 and the now comes King back to f3
King the g6 by Wesley and Bishop to e5
now the rook can't move from there as if
you get rook to b6 and then it could be
very dangerous so rook the e6 pushing
the bishop back and now rook the b5 just
defending we have looked back the a6 and
the now Bishop back to beat you Knight
h5 and here as you can see the pawn and
the knight control all the three squares
in front of across and skink and the
rook is not allowing any checks along
the sixth rank so it's sort of a
fortress Magnus
it's gonna be very hard to break through
we have looked the b8 by Magnus trying
to get rook g8 check and get the rook
over to g5 to kick away the night and
attack the f5 bone here and here it's
interesting some of someone mentioned in
the live chat that as the players have
do have heart monitor so they are
constantly monitoring their heart rate
cross and heart rate here was a D
whereas Wesley's was 120 so also
something to take into consideration
Wesley under much more stress here and
and lower on time yeah it's it's sort of
a position where Carlson is up upon he
can just play it indefinitely as well
there is no increment and hopefully he
wants to get Wesley as far down on time
as possible so he maybe he can even use
some flagging maneuvers in order to grab
a full point but okay Wesley decides for
rook to a5 he gives up the 6th ranked
but now the King can move and the rook
also guards df5 bond we have looked the
g8 with check King f7 and now rook the
g5 check Knight back to f6 the rook
covers the f5 one like we said and now
King to f4
so making some progress we have looked
the b5 attacking the bishop Bishop to e5
now and kink the e6 with a double attack
on the bishop cousin has to go back
Bishop to a-1 and now rook the a5 here
Wesley saying wherever you go with your
Bishop I'm just gonna keep on attacking
it
that's a weird arrow and if you go
something like here then I can even pin
it and force your King to go back so
here across and says okay you got me so
Bishop captures on f6 magnets decides to
trade
King captures and now rook the g8 so now
it's a rockin game our magnet Magnus is
up upon but the black King has a has a
very nice position here so look the a4
with check King f3 and now rook to a3
with check as there was another capture
the 50 move rule you know starts over so
as the capture happened on more 59 they
have to reach our move 109 for wasted to
be able to claim it wrong kingi to rip
the a to check with King to h3 and now
rook the a1 preparing more checks add
the more checks you give the faster you
get to the 50 move rule we have worked
the b8 by Magnus and now look back to a
two rook the b6 check with King to g7
and now rook the b4 we have king to g6
just repeating we have rook to f4 and
the now comes Luke the B to look to f1
by Magnus looked back to a2 and now look
the b1 by Magnus we have looked the c2
now rook the b6 with check King h5 so
what do you do here here we have looked
f6 is going after the pawn but now
looked at f2 just defending the pawn we
have looked a f8 going back and now King
back to g6 so everything is nicely done
here
Ruby g8 check with King to f7 and not
look back to a 8 by Magnus look back to
be 2 and now h5 Carson makes a pawn move
so the 50 move resets itself we have
King to g7 and now rook to a6 if you try
King to h4 here now too
at the g5 square for a king then Wesley
had Ruby for check in mind King here and
now Ruby for check where you can trade
here and this is just uh this is just
the wrong position because the white
king is completely caught off from from
the th pawn and the black the black ink
and very easily hold it so after King g7
we have looked the a6 going for Ruby g6
check now rook the b4 and now rook the
g6 with Czech king of seven and now King
back to G - Wesley starts another series
of checks rook checks King h3 and look
back to be for not allowing the King to
go for King gauge for King to g5 we have
looked the c6 by Magnus and now King g7
rook the a6 and now look the c-4 with h6
now let's check another pawn move so the
50 move rule resets itself King h7 and
now looked f6 going after the pawn but
now Wesley all he has to do is to keep
control of the of the fourth-ranked we
have rook to a4 so the King cannot
approach the position and if well if
Magnus captures here then you can just
capture some capture on h6 here we have
kinked the g2 not looked a3 not allowing
the white king to enter the game and
here magnets decided to trade rook
character skin captures and rook to f3
rook to f3 is basically a draw for
because King and pawn with the black
King being where where the backing is is
it Ross so here Wesley happily captured
we have King captures and now King to g5
and now the players didn't just agree to
a draw they decided to play it out and
to demonstrate to the world how to draw
this endgame g4
we have King to g6 now King to f4 we
have came to f6 going for opposition now
g5 check King g6 and now comes king of
the g4 y 2 gets opposition but it's not
a problem king f7 kinked f5 again
gaining opposition but now kink the g7
you cannot get your king in front of the
pawn so this is a draw g6 with King to
g8 and now King the f6 we have King to
f8 of course gaining another opposition
g7 check King g8 and now came to g6 and
here it's white who gets the last
opposition but black is in stalemate so
there are no more moves the black and
play that's another word eros of course
this is not a draw so a wonderful 96
move draw which really really a nice
fighting game and a very nice game by
both of them so that's the first game of
the classical section of the world fish
random championship between Magnus calls
and Wesley so I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Tony more guitar for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon I'll continuing the coverage of
the official random finals checking up
on the European World Team Championship
and of course on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day